Mark: Ahhhh...
Ohhhh...
Yeee...
I'm like Mario! Oh look at me! Oh look at me!
Okay, so I know what I gotta do... A little bit. ;w;
Hello, Hooty. What you hooting about over there?
Where are you going? Wait, come back, wait!
No! Hang on! I need - I think I need you! :(
I- I think- Ah...
Jiminy Christmas, where'd you go?
AH!
Oh, yeah. I'm fine. Okay. YAH!
*chuckles* Oh God. It's so uncomfortable for that to be stuck permanently underground like that...
Oh...
*grumbles* Anyway, what am I doing here?
*background scratch*
*door creaks open*
*chuckling with excitement*
Oh - hohohoho!
Hohohoho!
Hoho ha ha ha ha!
*creepy classical piano in background*
So - Whoah. What in the hell is that?
*creaking door...*
*SLAM*
Music stopped!
Mister orchestra, man, you could kick it up any time now.
It's a little weird being alone in this-
AHHHHHH!
Oh, it's dark!!
Ooahhh!!
I don't wanna play this game!
I don't wanna play it! I don't wanna play it. I do. Not. Want to. Play it.
*Creepy giggling in background*
Ooh!
Ooh. Hey, wow. You are pretty!
You seem to be...
Bulbous and...
Ohhhhhhhhh!
Bulbous...
I'm just gonna, like, caress your sweet, luscious - Oh!
Here we go.
Oh!
OH!!
Ghost: *giggles evilly*
Mark: *Stutters nervously*
Mark: "AH! EEEAH! OK!!"
Mark: I'm out! I'M OUT!! Ooooooo!
*slams door*
AHH! No! De- Da- WAH!
NO!
WOAH! WOAH! WOAH! WOAH! WOAH!
WOAH!
Wow!
Yeah, see how you missed me, and I don't miss me because I'm not bad -
Woah- er-ar-ah-
Ahhhh....!
(Thud)
My lower half! Where did it go!?
AHHH!
*crying* Help me!
Please! Somebody to something!
(Boink!)